these cows are having a field day eating
vegetables that many ordinary
Venezuelans can't farmers in Lolita are
having to throw away their produce
because there's no petrol to take it to
market this is my bread and butter the
only thing I have to support my family
President Nicolas Maduro blames us
economic sanctions for an acute petrol
shortage that's causing havoc
now he's removed the president of the
state oil company pay the visa and
replaced him with a key confidant tarik
le Sammy who's been indicted by the US
Justice Department for alleged drug
trafficking this comes just days after
the Trump administration gave Chevron
Corp the last major US oil company
operating in Venezuela it's marching
orders the Treasury Department has
announced they knew narrowly limited
license for seven months which roll out
companies that are operating there to
begin their winddown process the White
House is hoping that more of the same
sanctions but under worsening
circumstances will finally convince the
army to oust monoidal that will only
happen when the military feels confident
that they all maintained their corporate
power their physical integrity and their
economic interests and we're a long way
from that because for example the head
of the military is on washington's
blacklist
it's an inconsistent strategy meanwhile
an NGO that tracks political prisoners
reports that at least 70 people have
been detained in the last five weeks
since the nationwide Kovach 19 lockdown
was declared that includes 11 active and
retired members of the National Guard
involved in an alleged foiled uprising
last week opposition deputy Huang hua
NEPA says Maduro is using the quarantine
to further social control he manipulates
absolutely everything to give the
impression that everything is under
control
when the worst is still to come for now
there are no signs of a political
solution that could ease economic
sanctions and hardships but with the
crisis of such magnitude even the
unthinkable is possible to see a Neumann
out